قال وزير الخارجيه الصينيه انه من
الضروريه استقرار العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه وتجنب وقوع حوادث بين البلدين
واضاف الوزير الصيني خلال لقاء مع السفير
الامريكي في بيتجين انه يتوجب على الجانب
الامريكي تصحيح فهمه للصين والعوده الى
العقلانيه
وفق ما جاء في بيان للخارجيه الصينيه ان
على واشنطن التعامل بشكل صحيح مع قضيه
تايوان والتوقف عن تفريغ مبدا الصين
الواحد من مضمونه وعن دعم هو استقلال
تايوان الانفصاليه والتواطئ معها واكد ان
على واشنطن احترام الخط الاحمر ووقف ما
سماه الاضرار بسياده الصين وامنها
ومصالحها التنمويه من جهاته قال السفير
الامريكي نواشنطن لا تريد حربا بارده مع
بتجين وانها ترغب في قنوات تواصل دائمه
معها